welcome to simulation
hi atlas thanks for having me
i'm so excited for our episode together
me too i'm very excited i heard a lot of
good things about your
youtube channel and your podcast and i'm
very excited to be here
the show is a product of the guests
i know you just sit there and listen
[Laughter]
so tell me about a word
or one of the other famous words will
you unpack that for us
when i was in film school like for
documentaries one of the main
questions you'd ask someone is to phrase
it like
tell me about the moment you felt blah
blah blah blah
you just like have to phrase it all this
time like this way and i was like yeah
tell me your darkest deepest secret
yeah it's actually a pretty good
segue into what i want to talk about
first
yes we'll get to the
calling which you guys can see in the
ticker below sharok's calling is people
realizing how powerful they
are and we'll get there
by starting us off with
true tell us about your process
of awakening oh you're starting strong
okay um
it's interesting because i feel it was
gradual but at the same time
not like a massive shift but at the same
time when i look back at everything i've
done in my life
it was leading up to that moment um
but if we're gonna talk talk about like
the main shift that happened
it was in 2020 so
last year uh the pandemic happened
and i was living in new york
at that time new york city and i was
doing documentaries and podcast editing
and i'm just like starting off and like
everything was going well kind of but
not really because i was like
hitting rock bottom emotionally um
of like everything like i was like i
can't like this is too much everything
is happening right now like this race
everything that's going on like i i
don't want to even leave my room
um and but like i got like
some power and like so i'm like okay
like let's keep going everything is
gonna be fine
and then the pandemic happened and i
was still living in new york but then i
like completely
left and went to wisconsin and
i stayed with my partner there and
i was like planning on just like going
there for like two weeks and then going
back to new york like everything's fine
and i never left i just stayed there i
didn't have any work
i didn't have anything and i just
started asking questions
it like started with like very simple
questions of like okay
so what kind of documentaries do i want
to make like i
really want to do documentaries i'm very
passionate about it i'm very passionate
about other people's stories and so on
but like what kind of stories and like
why am i even doing them
and i was like wait what kind of music
do i like to listen to
like what's happening like i don't even
know my preferences
and i was like wait like everything i do
is has been told to me by other people
and i don't even know like what is my
style like how do i want to express
myself
and i realize that i don't know a lot
about myself
and i was like getting really
interesting um
and like right before that uh my
roommate in new york
introduced me to tarot and
i was okay so i grew up muslim
and i like did my investigation and like
everything about like people
like with their belief systems
and like just like believing in
something or devoting their life
to it without any logic involved so that
was like a big
red flag to me so like i dissected that
and i was like okay like
no that doesn't make any sense to me
like if i'm gonna follow something i
have to have logic behind it and i don't
need a book to tell me to be
kind to other human beings like it
doesn't make any sense
so i had a very strong stand on that
like i never called myself an atheist or
anything i was like okay if there's
a higher power great if there isn't okay
like i don't care
um but then fast forward to 2019 my
roommate in new york introduced me to
tarot
and i was like wait like i am actually
enjoying this like this is like helping
me
analyze things about my life and like so
on
uh but there was always this thing in
the back of my mind like this is crazy
like you're turning crazy right now
this is like what you used to like
consider like oh like just like whoa
and crazy and we don't want to open that
can of worms and like so on
and um but i was really enjoying it so i
just like kept going
with that and i wasn't like thinking
anything like big about it
and then when 20 um in 2019 also like a
big moment
that made a shift for me uh was
my partner went to rehab for being like
an alcoholic
and when she came back like she started
talking about like
her process and everything and like how
there is a higher power
and that like stuck with me i was like
wait
i trust this person she's very analytic
like
smart intellectual like very has like
she has a very good grasp on everything
if she thinks
there's a higher power i'm giving myself
a permission slip
to like go and like dive deep in like
the things that i want to dive deep into
so like when 2020 happened and i started
asking these questions
i was like okay i really need to figure
out what's going on
because it's apparent that i don't know
anything about anything
and i'm just like auto piloting this
entire time so like let's take a deep
breath
and figure it out um
and whenever like i like looked into
spirituality
i looked into like a lot of different
topics and
one example was like i read an
explanation of the course of miracles
and one big thing that was said was like
love is the main thing and fear
is not true it's fake
so i was like okay well how do we
dissect this so i went to like
scientific experiments that are looking
at fear
and how do we develop fear and then i
realized that we just pick up fear
and it doesn't have any actual thing to
stand
on that is just like if i see like it's
like a program like if i see atlas
scared about something
i get scared about it and now it's like
engraved in my
mindset that like now i'm getting scared
of like this box
that i shouldn't be scared about and i
was like okay so like basically all the
fears i have are irrational fears that
they don't have anything to stand on so
now i understand
what they mean by love is what's real
and fear is not what's like fear is fake
and i was like so what does love mean is
it like the romantic family friendship
kind of love or is this like
something even deeper and i looked into
that and i was like wait
love is
looking at everyone as yourself like
realizing if you were in anyone's
shoes and anyone's anything you would
act exactly the same
so like how can you and like by judging
anyone you're basically judging yourself
and i was like okay
so that is unconditional love that if
you see anyone doing
anything that like according to your
beliefs of right or wrong
doesn't match you still love them you
still care about them you still
see them they see beyond the
definitions and the labels of like
what's wrong and what's right
and like the fears and all of these
stuff you'll be able to actually see
that entity for like how perfect and
amazing they are and you would have
exactly done that same thing
and that was like a huge huge shift
and also then i started like
looking into so who am i
i was like okay it's like i have like
all these thoughts and all these like
programmed fears and like
all of this stuff so who am i
with like all these things and then i
started like looking at experiments with
memories
of like okay so like if someone uh
completely erased their memory for
example they still exist
they still operate they just don't have
a reference so like your memory
is not actually who you are you're very
malleable
and like i am whatever story i tell
myself
and then i start looking at the story i
was telling myself and i was like
my god like i'm telling myself a very
shitty story
that is not cool
like i started like even like journaling
and writing like
all the things i say to myself all the
things that i
look at like i say and like operate as
and i was like this is not
true this is not even my thoughts like
these are all stuff that i picked up
along the way
from like either people told me that or
i perceived it that way
and for like and i just believed it
and it felt ah it felt such freedom that
i can
be anything i want to be like there's
not a specific story that this is like
shrew who grew up in egypt who did blah
blah blah blah
and now this is how i act it's like all
like predictable
it was it was just empty
and there was no meaning
to anything and that was so liberating i
was like wait
nothing i always like struggled with
decisions like making decisions with
like which path is the right path and
what is
like the right thing and i was actually
watching a movie that i watched so many
times called mr nobody
i love that movie i watched it so many
times and the last time i watched it
there was this sentence which said every
path is the right path
and will have as much meaning and i was
like oh my god that's so true because i
am the one who gives meaning to things
things don't have meaning all of this
is just empty and meaningless and the
situations are
completely empty i was like it
was that was a massive massive thing
because i felt
like okay like this is just the
playground or like just having fun
um and then my attention went to
um start asking the question of like how
was the universe created
i wanted to know that because like okay
like with like spirituality like they
keep saying
and religions that they keep saying that
you're a soul
and then i was like okay well that does
make sense but what is this
like what is this body is this like a
very advanced machine
that we're like in right now like but
how are we
in this like it just like things did not
make sense
and i looked for answers i was like but
like it doesn't make sense like how am i
even moving this
what is this and where am i
in this so i started like asking
questions about that and i start looking
at like laws
in um i don't want to say i don't know
if like science
or like theory or any of this but like
for example like paradise law
and like several other laws of like that
there are
certain probabilities to things there
are certain like
um design for things and
like seeing the math like being formed
and like how
like always like end up being the same
and like i was like wait there are
there is a design to this like this it's
very obvious
and i just proved it so what is this
and i started asking these questions and
i even remember saying it out loud
several times
to like my friends it was like i'm not
gonna stop until i figure out how the
universe was created
it's i don't care about anything else
right now
um and i yeah i even
told you this before i just like was
sitting on my porch and i opened tik tok
and um i saw this like one video it just
like popped up in front of me
and it was suggestion for like three
videos
one was the law of one one was for
bentino
and one for like i don't even know it's
like one wounded
child or like whatever so i was like
okay like i'm gonna check out these like
things to see what are these videos and
i had no clue what they were all about
and the first video that i watched was
about the law firm explaining how the
universe was created
and my like mind was blown and i was
like it like
innately knew that all of this was true
that all of this like it just like
resonated so much it was like it felt
like
i'm remembering it like not like
studying it it was
like yeah like i even like ran to my
porch and like sat there and i was like
oh my god it's a symphony
it's such a beautiful symphony and we're
all just
playing parts in it and we're like the
orchestrator of it all it was like such
a
beautiful moment i was so excited and i
was like i finally figured it out
i know what we're doing and it matches
up with everything i've been like
contemplating on and researching and
like even like using like
my logical ability to deconstruct things
and like be able to see through things
that
all made sense it was the first time i
was reading
a book that was actually like
very comprehensive and it's very like in
your face it's so true
like you can't hide it you can't like
ignore it
um and then like i took my time looking
into that and reading the books and so
on and then i
i looked at the other video which was
continue as far as teaching
and um it was a video
about like you are source and
i was like yes makes sense it a lot it's
aligned with
everything i've been like looking at
with a lot of one
and i even like wanted to like gauge the
credibility
of like okay i want to see his own
explanation or like if he even has
any work on the law of fun because the
law of one really resonated with me
and then i looked it up and i was like
oh great he does
sweet we're on the same page
and it was it was just like everything
was just mind-blowing like everything
changed
so fast um and
like even like with the mary talks
podcast when he's like deconstructing a
lot of things and like especially
like the relationship episode it was a
confirmation for me
because it was okay like this is what
i've been thinking about for years this
is how i've been living my life
like i don't see relationships as real
or as like human like make them to be
and when i
saw his explanation of that i like knew
like this was like
aligned it was yeah it was like a
confirmation
and yeah i just took it and ran with it
like i was like staying like
eight to nine hours a day just like
studying watching videos contemplating
journaling about like everything i say
to myself everything i think about
like why do i do these things why
everything
i was just like because i got really
excited
when i started this journey when i
realized that the only thing i need was
myself
i was like oh my god this is like my
ex acceptance letter to hogwarts and the
only thing i need
is me and that's it
i was really excited i was like okay so
like the only thing i need to do is just
like keep working on myself
and that's it and yeah and then venting
you
um started like the mentorship
and even before that when i was like
figuring out what manifestation was
because i remember all these stuff were
like
very new to me uh what manifestation was
i
wrote a letter to the universe
uh like and addressed it in a past
like past term uh language
that thank you so much for the mentor
that i got and thank you so much
for the family that i got and that was
in august in december and like then i
ran into like maintenance teachings and
a lot of one in like september
and like october and so on and in
december banting you started the
mentorship group
and i of course applied and i got in
and yeah here we are and i met you
that's it
i love sharok's story so much i love
how even in just like the last
year really
so much of the
common theme with
these dreamed creations
is that in this third density upon
self-awareness setting in there's this
very autopiloty matrixy scripted
like you said is everything that i do a
product of scripts that other people
have
indoctrinated me into do have i
ever willed anything what do i even like
yeah who am i like what kind of music do
i like what kind of documentaries
do i want to make like that kind of like
these very fundamental questions like am
i
literally just a product of like my
parents
and my society my community the media
or do i literally have sovereignty do i
have choice do i have will what do i
want to create who do i want to become
what is in my north star position what
is in my calling position
and so there's that like bentino says
there's the unfreezing
of will and gaining of spiritual mass
and you clearly went through that same
thing with me
very much so in 2020 a lot of that
and i love your
i love your honing in on
the synthesis of things like
law of one with bentino's teachings
it really answers the fundamental
question that you became so passionate
about which i think that
as nisargadatta says that the
earnestness
is key so if you have that question of
i am not going to stop until
i know how and why the universe was
created
because if you start with that question
of
okay the gig's up like i'm done
running 28 years of scripts
like i'm done it's over like now i'm
asking the questions
what the [ __ ] is this reality about who
the
[ __ ] are we why are we here to get the
gigs up
it's done uh
and then and then when you get so past
like so now there's the spectral
differences
even if you ask the question we could
even say that maybe even 10
of the planet has asked themselves the
question
but now the spectrum is
i'm interested enough in that question
to invest
one hour per week into the question
versus the literally i am going to wake
up
and study this question for eight hours
per day
up to 15 hours per day
until i go to bed and do it for a year
until i figure out how and why we are
here
yeah and that's the other side of the
spectrum
of the people that even ask themselves
the question
and so the more that you have
earnestness on that side of the spectrum
to figure out
okay what is my true nature what's going
on here
that you will the truth will yield and
when
when the truth yields you are [ __ ]
liberated and
there's just nothing more freeing
there's nothing more peaceful there's
nothing that brings more happiness
there's nothing that brings more love
light unity to everything that you
engage with because you know it's all
that one intelligence at play with
itself
you're the very source of this infinite
exploration
you're what's comprehending this
infinite exploration
and so and like you said
there's also a massive liberation from
even the realization of the emptiness of
it
because then there's no attachment to
any of it i'm not attached to the dream
becoming enlightened yeah all this type
of stuff
and in any way it's a natural function
as
you know pentino has been saying with
the
ignition of the global awakening that's
why it's called the
ignition because it's already a natural
unfolding process
and the no limit society is kind of like
adding a little bit of that fuel like
acceleration
and and that's a beautiful shared
exploration that we're going through
right now you
and i and mesh and so many others
are going through this process together
and it's very beautiful
and it's an honor and that's why we
gravitated to
here because of things like what
happened with bentino over the last
decade
what's happened with the raw lineage and
the law of one becoming more and more
accessible
and people from around the world
becoming more and more excited about
your talks podcast and been to your
global enlightenment retreat
and the synthesis of basically
self-realization enlightenment
non-duality
with self-actualization with
individuation with empowerment because
the two are ultimately one and
that seems to be one of the core
essences of what's
really drawing us here and being
pure stewards pure shepherds
in a non-attached way and i'm so
pumped because your story is
it's a quintessential example of what
happens
when you unfreeze your will and you ask
yourself the most important questions
and you dedicate yourself full time
to the truth yielding yeah
yeah i believe empowerment is like taken
all the way it leads to enlightenment
like the more you realize your power the
more you realize that like
all of this is in you like it's not like
someone is trying to tell you something
like like you i can say things
till tomorrow and you'll never believe
me you need to have this
spark in you of like do i even know who
i
am like it's like a very basic question
and i
couldn't believe that i lived this
entire time without asking that question
of like who am i what is this
and it's yeah it's like it's a huge
power and it's
i am very happy that my journey was
uh like took these turns and like took
all of this because
and it's very aligned with my calling to
realize that
yeah i am very powerful and i
belt it from scratch up and it's
and it's so much fun because it like
raises your conviction to you like it's
not just like
i read these stuff and it resonates i
did
all the research and like everything of
like
realizing like yeah like no i know i got
here by my own
logic and convection hand in hand and
they go hand in hand
yeah and now it's like becoming even
even way more clear that i don't have
even a shred of doubt of like i know i
am
here on earth like i know why i came i
know what
calling i answered when i decided to
incarnate on earth of like yeah cool
it's like we're doing this shift and i'm
coming and it's going to be so much fun
it's going to
be a healthy ride and
i don't even have like any like shirt of
doubt about that
and it's because i saw the vein and
emptiness
of the human ways
like i played it i got really
like i was living in new york city like
let's just put that in mind
i was like very much in the game and
i tried every single thing it like
always did not make sense to me
that it was that i would see people
around me finding
what they want to study or what they
want to be and they get for me it was
like i don't know is there something
wrong with me
like what's going on i can't find the
reason
like something that is actually sparking
my interest like i get interested about
this thing for like few days or a month
and then
that's it like i went to school so many
times so many times i get like
four degrees and
i like it just like nothing satisfied
that curiosity and that like passion and
not
nothing sparked that fire as much as
like when i started asking these
questions
and realizing who i am and it's suddenly
everything fits
so of course i don't have any doubts
i love your focus on that it's probably
the easiest way for
for people to
understand the true nature is really
just
asking the biggest questions
one of the main reasons why asking the
biggest questions is
not done is because we've
invested so much time into this
this lattice work in the mind
and especially of being a
separate entity and
that this ultimate arrogance
of separating oneself completely from
the creation
that gave rise to you yeah
oh my god that assumption of a separate
entity is so funny
like the more you even look at it it's
like wait why
like how can i even take pride in my
thoughts how can i even take pride in
any of these things or say it's mine
when i have no clue where they came from
i have no clue they just pop out and
like or pop up
in my mind and then i like take pride in
them or like say that they are me or
like i
did them and ultimately you did but not
from this level of consciousness
you didn't do anything like you're just
part of the dream
it's like like did do you think the
trees
like even care if it's snowing or
raining or it's sunny like they don't
care
it's like all part of the beam like the
turtle comes out of
like the ocean to go and like walk
across the ocean to like put its
eggs and then like the baby turtles come
and they know
they have to go to the ocean where did
that come from like the arrogance of
thinking that
we know better that the intelligence
that created us
without even knowing how were we created
it's it's very arrogant and it's very
hilarious actually to think about it
when you think you know anything
as you said out of these biggest
questions
i really appreciated your focus on the
who am i question the classical
contemplative approach of self-inquiry
and then also the
i love your power here too i am not
going to stop until i figure out how and
why
the universe was created and
i really feel like those are two of the
biggest questions and in
true earnest pursuit
of those questions relentlessly
the seeker will get exhausted
because it will have the truth yielded
and then the seeker is like [ __ ] yeah
got it
i'm good i'm absolute freedom i'm
absolute perfection it's all love light
und i play with itself
[ __ ] yeah like and then it's just
it's just chill like life is just
chill and it's cool and
there's there's no more
of the
the patterns of behavior that cause
malevolence and suffering and disaster
and destruction
and it's just more of
i know the patterns and i know the
behaviors that are
the one intelligence playing with itself
and
i'm gonna non-attachedly
shepherd that process
and and then it's abundance and its
prosperity and its
enlightenment and empowerment and gift
actualization and
play and dance and sing and nature
and architecting
all of the future technologies and
protocols that enable these next
kids that pop into the world to
be able to enjoy the playground
that it is yeah
yeah it's it's a symphony it's fun we
came here to play
and we're just taking it so serious and
like by
saying you came here to play it doesn't
mean being complacent but we're
it's like have some fun enjoy it like do
you know how lucky you are
to be part of this to be witnessing this
to be radiating this love and light into
like this huge
like symphony like everything is alive
everything is
playing and experimenting and having fun
we just like forget
and we get like so serious about it and
then we start to suffer
and we start like oh how can i get out
of the suffering that i created
in the game that i am part of it's so
hilarious
like okay it's okay
i also love how you brought up the
the natural intelligence that is all
around us
you know leonardo da vinci said that
nature is the best teacher
it's all around us all the time and
we're just not
subtle enough or we're not slow enough
to be able to detect it
because the mind is always trying to
draw us to
doing and when we just relax
into being so much opens up
and so many of these insights like what
you
described about trees and turtles
and the really in the process of even
us as as humans we become more subtle to
things like in the law of one and what
continue talks about with catalysts
and distortions and really recognizing
those things
quicker and at deeper layers of subtlety
and course correcting
and seeing myself the way that god sees
me yeah and that and that type of
resonance
there is what we're talking about
and less of the separate
arrogant energy
yeah yeah
yeah it makes a big difference when you
just
take a deep breath and lessen and
just tune in for a second like stop
arguing
makes a huge difference become like
humble and
open and joyful and like a baby again
like like our true nature
like right now we're just like arguing
all the time and we think that like when
we're mad at everything and we're mad at
everyone
and we don't know that we're the ones
creating all of that
that's the irony of it
when did yeah go ahead uh
i was actually gonna tell you it's
probably not a common thing you have on
your show
but uh can we take a minute break yeah
go go take a break yeah take a minute
take a minute break i'll be
here okay okay so you take a minute
break and i'll hold the space of
the show while until you come back yes i
give you the torch again
okay we'll see you in a little bit okay
[Music]
foreign
hi atlas
yay with all the
research and everything i've done i have
not been able to control my platter yet
so i'm
still working on that one
i'm glad that you're able to be relieved
and it makes the
conversation more smooth i agree
yes yes let's play
with the calling
so when did people realizing how
powerful they are
come through and tell us about the
process of
what that means to you
really good question so
throughout this journey um i was very
like because because it was really
interesting right like i did
i was asking these questions and i
didn't know
where these questions were leading me so
everything was unpredictable and
everything was like i don't even know if
i'm up to something or not but what i'm
doing is interesting
and i'm excited about it so just keep
going
um and it's
i even like had this terror reading once
and i was very like down at that moment
of like okay like i've been like
doing this for a few months now
and like very impatient and it's like
i've been doing this for a few months
now and i still have not figured it out
and i want to and the message that i got
was you're learning how
to build up everything from scratch
and i was like okay like that makes
sense a little bit like i get it
and then when i got into like continuous
working
and like his work and like everything
and i got introduced to the calling and
especially that was like
in the mentorship like i didn't know my
calling or what is the calling before
the mentorship
because um i was like okay like i'm that
one infant creator like cool like this
is what i need to know right
um but then on like the mentorship we
started having that conversation
about the calling and so on and i had
a conversation with corey
um and uh she's like you know cory she's
part of ventino's team for the people
who don't know
and um she asked me the first thing on
the call what's your calling and i said
people realizing how powerful they are
and it just like came out of
me and uh and i was like oh like i
didn't even know
if this is like was like the right or
iteration of the calling or not and she
was like usually it's like the first
thing that comes out of you
and um i start looking at like my
lack beliefs and like my limitation and
like the conditioning
thoughts and it was so obvious
that it was everything like any
conditioning thought or any like belief
was the complete opposition of my
calling
complete opposition like i want you to
realize how powerful
you are but if i'm insecure i don't want
you to realize how powerful
you are it was like very like
opposition and it was kind of crazy i
was like wow like this like makes things
way more
like it's very simple right like now i
can look at this thought or this action
or this thing and it's like where is it
coming from
black beliefs or my calling because it's
making things so easy for me
and i started even looking at like my
life and like everything and i was like
yeah i
lived a journey that or like i designed
this incarnation to actually realize how
powerful i am
like from the scratch up and like
it's pure willpower like we with
our willpower we can do anything we can
literally move mountains
we can do anything with our willpower
and i had to live that like i had to see
i had to like conjure that up i had to
live the opposition of that i had to see
the opposition of that and how was that
like
where that would lead me to bring up
this
force of like the
intention that brought me here and now
like the more i'm constituted as my
calling in every single
minute or interaction or anything i see
people light up
like and without even me mentioning that
my calling is people realizing how
powerful they are
they tell me that like they tell me like
whenever i hang out with you or whenever
we're having these conversation
i feel powerful and i'm like yeah
because i am constituted as my calling
i'm radiating that energy like it's not
about what i say it's not about anything
it's about like having having it as your
north star
and it's not about like the words even
it's about like that
essence of it like that essence of you
that is like
ah like i'm so lit up i'm like so
on top of the mountain right now i am
the one infinite
creator experiencing the itself like
this
and i have all the power i want and i
have all the limitations and it's fun
like i get to experience the limitless
in
a limited environment and it's it's
magnificent
it's amazing so i really really like the
calling because it simplifies
things and puts things into perspective
and gets you
gives you a chance to tap into
that essence of you that frequency that
like really lights you up
did that answer your question
will you unpack more for us how
on the other side of your
calling you've found
almost like the calling work is like the
tree fruits and branches and then the
core lack belief or weakness work is the
roots
of the reaching down to hell
like very jungian in the sense of that
the roots reach down to hell in order
for the branches to reach the
heavens and so that they're kind of like
two sides of the same
coin like for me the
core lack belief weakness is
needing to be seen as the lightbringer
for all these metaphysical credits oh
look at that
look at that atlas character oh it has
the truth
oh he's a gold star outlet
gold star on forehead for the atlas
character
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah exactly exactly but on
the other side
is the my calling is people experiencing
truth
right so they play so beautifully into
each other like that
it brings you back it's like whoop like
now you're in alignment when you think
of your calling because like all the
other
[ __ ] stuff is just like dragging you
everywhere and then you think of your
calling for a second and it's like
okay i'm good now
um yeah i think actually the calling is
the root
i mean it is the root like i get like
the metaphor that you were saying of
like oh it's like reaching down to hell
and like one reaching up to the sky
but i think the calling is
our route we just picked up all these
stuff on top of it and we thought it was
just
part of the tree which is part of the
tree it's fine we just we agreed on that
like we wanted that
we were like yeah like i could have like
stayed up like and
up right i could have like stayed like
in like harmony and peace and love and
like not pick up any of these like
struggles and lack beliefs and like
define them negatively and so on but i
wanted that
i wanted to bring forth my calling
through its opposition
and i wanted to feel helpless
and not powerful and not have a say in
anything
and not taken care of and have to fend
for myself
to see that i am none of that
and i'm all of it and it's i think
it's beautiful like the whole design of
like this
third density incarnation is brilliant
it's like this not just the third
density but like everything else
but especially this one it's so
brilliant it's like i'm gonna know
myself through the opposition
like i'm gonna pick up everything that
is not me and i'm gonna forget who me is
and i'm gonna think that i am
all these things so i can bring forth
myself with like
conviction devotion and logic and
will and it's like you where else would
you get that
if we're like living in rainbows and
butterflies all the time how
like where else would you get that
and it's yeah and that makes things very
clear
the very contrast
is what brings clarity so
the very
contrast of identifying a core lack
belief
or a weakness is exactly what brings
the clarity of purifying where one's
coming from
by repeatedly working on the roots
of being one intelligence that play with
itself rather than being a separate
entity extracting from the
creation
[Music]
yeah there's a lot of analogies to play
with
on the roots and
karma yoga is one of the best from
thousands of years selflessly
selflessly serve no expectation
whatsoever with the fruits like
what bashar also said you know
perpetually
act in your highest excitement to the
best of your ability
zero insistence
on the outcome and the fruits zero
and i was on a call with mark
yesterday and he was like
zero zero he's like
not not 0.00
percent insistence and i was like damn
this shit's lit
like we're like talking like
like in the thousandth decimal point
like
no chance like you have to be like an
absolute zero
because otherwise you suffer right and
then like you go into like this whole
like consequences of your
actions and desires and like the the
wheel
of like karma and we all suffering and
like all of these stuff
and it's just because we are not an
absolute zero
we still have like this decimal thing
like
creeping in the background
yeah oh my gosh that's why i asked that
question to bentunio too on the
on the forum with that new nls
perk that we're exploring with asking a
question to bentino it's really exciting
because
what the answer that he's found for
years and years and years of dealing
with these
sneakiest cheekiest forms of
conditioning and like
what mark was saying like this
thousandth
decimal place of like
oh yeah i'm completely surrendered and
non-attached and then like in this
tiniest
most hidden place like speck of
subatomic
oh i have a little bit of insistence on
the outcome like
that kind of stuff is gonna be
fascinating for us to
explore and it'll be interesting to hear
what bentino and the rest of the team
sort of have found to be these
most sneaky cheeky
like like this is really interesting
be probably because i'm i would say that
i'm kind of at this place where i'm
trying to figure out what is sneaky and
cheeky about like
about what's hiding here like i'm trying
to figure this [ __ ] out like this is
it's like part of the fun game of the
one intelligence licking
looking at itself and being like okay
where am i still trying to extract like
it's it's very clever it's very clever
and you have to be vigilant attentive
and aware
so much and like also balance it off
like not judging these like nuances when
they come
and like be
a loving detective kind of
loving perspective i love that like
that's how i see myself i like i love
detective
like work of like i'm gonna analyze
everything
that's in me know yourself right like
the stuff not like your absolute self
you'll get there
but like as a starting point you need to
know like all the stuff that like
you think it's you and
[Music]
you just have to be vigilant about it
consistent with it always give it your
best like 100
every single time when it comes up to
give it your best
in like analyzing it and loving it
in accepting it in learning from it
and as bentinius as just the muscle
like you start like noticing like higher
level like nuances and like subtleties
and like it gets more interesting right
because it's like
now we're stepping up a new level new
devil
kind of thing
a friend said that to me and i was like
this is so true
um but one thing that ventiniu
said and it was such a relief for me
unlike the murtax was
um something along these lines of course
i'm paraphrasing
um but like
to always always give it your all and
always
ask where you're coming from and always
be
like fall in love with the journey fall
in love with it
because it's not it's not a
one night thing it takes time and each
level
you reach you get a new thing you get a
new devil like on the screen right now
like you get um it takes
it takes work and time and you just have
to fall in love with it
like i had so much frustration at the
beginning so much of like
how long is this taking like when am i
gonna get to the god state like come on
and like all these distortions and all
these things like okay i've been like
working hard for a few months
and like i need to get like through this
and when i heard him say that if like
always like
follow your seeking impulse and just
fall in love with the journey
fall in love with the process because we
created all this for the process
not for the end result we were the end
result
and the more i fall in love with the
process the more i fall in love with the
journey
the easier it becomes and the more fun
it becomes
because um the way and the mentorships
hit that ones if i'm not playing
i'm not seeing his gut sees yes
and i completely agree
don't take it serious
i mean so many good ones there there's
this one
we created it for the process for the
whole song slash dance
not for the last note
i'm not listening to this song to get to
the three minute mark and just
listen to the last note yeah yeah
and i love this one too this one's great
if i'm not playing not seeing as god
sees
that's right
[Laughter]
and i love that intention it's so it's
so cool
it's like uh it's like
sri aurobindo and the mother mural fossa
talk about it like taking on
creator consciousness like taking on the
consciousness of being that which
designed the universe to play with
itself
yeah yeah the architect yes yes
yeah like um i told you this before like
continue and we were doing the exercise
of like if you see yourself as god sees
you
what would you do or what would you
change and
we all like wrote like i like me
personally i was like i would love
myself so much i wouldn't ever
like judge myself i would never uh i
would like be
like part of the symphony it was like
very romantic right and it's fine and
it's great because it's like
this is the gap that i need to fill but
on the next call we had he was like if
you really see yourself as
god sees you your answer would be i'm
gonna go create a solar system
like that's what you would do like you
are the architect you're the designer
you want to play you want to create you
want to experiment
and
just give it all every second
yeah from mesh it's a good one if we
were playing music with the intention of
getting to the end the fastest piano
play
player would be the best that's so true
thanks russian allen was
yeah that's very true
it's like also like because we live in
like the civilization or our collective
is like very because i didn't use
i didn't use to enjoy the process at all
like i was
impatient i was
always want to get to the next thing i
can see what i need to do and i want to
like jump into it
and like all of this and
when i looked at the environment or our
collective
when i was like contemplating on all
these like big
um concept was like oh we live in an
instant gratification
environment where everything you need
everything you want
is like given to you
very fast they so that you don't even
enjoy the process of like how was that
coffee made
from like the beginning of like or what
is like this animal that i am eating or
like what is this thing of like we just
see the final product we start we see
the final
version of things without appreciating
all the work and all the process and all
the things that happened to get you
this and
[Music]
i was like okay like i need to stop
looking at the word as a final product i
need to start looking at it as a process
that everything generated this
i am that which generates
this divine play for myself
and undergoes the process of
forgetting that i did set process
and then remembering that i did set a
process
across endless oddities
meanwhile i
never
go on any odyssey
and within that process you get so mad
at yourself
and you call yourself god and you get
mad so mad at yourself like why did you
do that to me
it's so funny sharok how do you see
people realizing their power moving
forward
what's the optimal
way for is it via the
self-realization and self-actualization
processes
i think just ask questions um
just the previous questions yeah like
even like if it started with small
questions
just ask questions and
because we also like where the
collective is at right now
it's very polarized right so like
whenever you're asking a question
it's very like can easily be boxed
into like oh now i'm like becoming crazy
or now i'm like oh
um turning to this side or turning to
that side or this is a conspiracy theory
or whatever just take all of that out of
your
mind and between you and yourself
even though there's only one of you just
sit down and start asking questions
start asking why do you do the things
you do
why are you even like saying these words
right now
as simple as that and it starts it
gets bigger and you start how powerful
you start realizing how powerful
you are and that you have the power of
choice in every single second
and that makes a shift
when you realize that you are the
painter of everything it makes
a big shift yeah
i really love the focus on the questions
i think it's so
so beautiful it's like even if you
are in a very
matrixy scripty
style day-to-day just even that
tiny little okay if i take the single
question
of why am i here
what's the point of the universe and if
i just
begin even if it's just at the beginning
with a little bit of earnestness
just beginning to navigate that you'll
more and more
unfreeze the will will more and more
gain spiritual mass
one unites with the intelligence that is
always present but that
seems to be lost
yeah so i'm glad that
i'm glad that you mentioned that because
it's it's really that simple
at the level of just asking
oneself a question to get oneself
unfrozen of those scripts and more and
more turned
inward investigating yeah
the loving detective huh the loving
detective
god that was such a good one
yeah it's because you are choosing it in
every minute you are making decisions
you're just autopiloting and then you
have opinions about a lot of things
through that autopiloting and if you
just
how i always saw it was that like a
scene in grand
central in new york that's how i
imagined it right with like everyone
like running everywhere and it's like so
crowded and you just like
stand there in like stillness
between like everyone just like running
around and that's
asking questions where you're like wait
a minute
i need to stop what's going on and
it opens doors that when you ask a
question
a clear question to your self or like
higher self is like
benjini said that like there's they have
to respond
if you are clear if you have conviction
if you
are dedicated it will you will get the
answer
in one way or another it's just
up to your own free will do you want to
know or you don't want to know
the answers are out there out there
right they're all inside of you
but you just need to start asking
that's been one of my favorite
activities also
like you described which is basically
you can even do this at home
when you're just walking
you're on your way to do something and
you just literally
stop
yeah and just like do that and then
like he'll kind of like re-establish
yourself in the essence of the one
intelligence
in a way that's more playful and also
more
in awe rather than
like following actions you're almost
taking
the time to be like
wait we made an
internet in this stream to talk to each
other
to talk to myself like
like appreciating all of the little
things like all the experiences you're
having
in like this like vehicle right or like
this human body it's like even like the
ability
to like have sensations or like
smell something or like see something or
like look at
like as you said like the creating
internet and this dream to talk to each
other even though it's just a monologue
like we're having a monologue right now
it's like consciousness talking to
itself but we created all these
distortions
within that to have all these different
kind of experiences and all the
these different kind of point of views
and
that's why like i love that they
continue said this before like even
though it is a dream
the dream is so relevant like enjoy the
dream
but know that you're dreaming like know
that this is just consciousness talking
to itself
and it's like has all these forms and
all of the like this cup
this shirt this headphones that you have
on like all this stuff
and that doesn't even exist right now
because we're just
dreaming but enjoy it you did that
yeah there's
nothing right now that is more beautiful
than this atlas
costume talking to the true costume
about the one intelligence at play with
itself there was just
i couldn't i couldn't
create anything more beautiful than
what's happening right now
and to like melt truly
into that that's what we're talking
about with the one heart that's what
we're talking about with spirituality
that's what we're talking about with
this divine
shift into that realignment and then
this non-attachment to
shepherding the awakening in the stream
and so i would highly recommend
for those listening that have enjoyed
the conversation with sharok and i to
also check out
the other conversations with the
no limits society members that we have a
playlist on our channel for
you can check that out you can check out
the link in the bio below
to civilizationupgraders.com forward
slash society
sharok do you have social platforms that
you
have people follow you i have my
instagram yeah
i don't post a lot there but it's
yeah it's first name last name sure
gilmaddy and
it's just a handle perfect we'll have
the link in the bio below to sharok's
instagram
and do you feel
content would you like to say anything
else prior to rapping
i am very happy that we're having this
monologue
and we're playing i had so much fun
me too and it's like really cool
to like talk to myself in this amazing
form that you are
and contemplate
on what we created so it's been so much
fun to have me to have
me on your show um i enjoyed every
conversation of it
but the simulation is glitching
i feel like yeah sharok and i are
at the beginnings of a very beautiful
friendship and
will be exciting to see how this
continues unfolding
yeah i am really glad that i met this
individuated spark of the
infant creator and yes yes
there's a lot of play when our shards
reflect
yes i like that
it's fun cool thanks everyone for tuning
in
infinite love we're super grateful thank
you
thank you thank you
we would love for you to like the video
if it brought you value helps the
algorithm subscribe to the channel if
you haven't yet
also leave us a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode
and people realizing their power would
love to hear from you
and share the episode with people that
you feel like this would
resonate with and make positive impact
on
and that is ah thanks sharok
thanks atlas
okay i'm gonna end the stream and we'll
stay
in the studio